- So we joke about robots
taking over, but they're really
helpful for police, so
what's the big deal?
Well, let's take a look.
And there is the robot.
That looks like your classic
Boston Dynamics robot.
- I've never seen nothing
like this before in my life.
- Yeah, me neither. I've
never seen that either.
- Oh, that (bleep)
walks better than a dog.
- Somehow it doesn't look
as cute when it's dressed up
as a police officer and police livery.
And this raises all kinds
of fourth amendment issues.
According to the Supreme
court in Terry vs Ohio,
the police are allowed to detain
and search people if there
is a reasonable suspicion.
But what does that mean
in the context of robots.
Who might have sensors
that are far more sensitive
than humans.
They might be just patrolling around.
Does that give them the
ability to stop people
just using a remote-controlled robot?
Does it infringe on
constitutional liberties?
This is not an issue
that is going to go away.
Police departments are
probably going to use more
and more robots, but we'll
see what the courts say.